>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Marisa: Please join me in
welcoming Kathleen Glasgow.
[ Applause ]
>> Kathleen: Thank you so much
for coming to see me today,
and I'd like to thank the National
Book Festival and the Library
of Congress for putting on this
great event and inviting me.
I want to also thank
the city of Washington,
DC because without Washington,
DC, I literally would not exist.
My parents met when
they were at Georgetown.
So that's my tie to the city.
I used to visit here a lot.
I grew up in Pennsylvania, and we
used to come up a lot in the 70s
and go see some of their
old college friends and go
to what they called rent parties.
Does anybody know what
a rent party is or was?
And it's when you can't pay your
rent, so you throw a big party
and your friends all come and they
give you like a couple of bucks
at the door towards your
rent, and my siblings
and I probably should not have
been going to those parties,
but it was the 70s and I remember
it as being like a lot of fun,
and maybe that's partly
what made me a writer.
A lot of people ask me how I
came to write "Girl in Pieces,"
which is the story of Charlie
Davis who uses self-harm to cope
with her intense emotional trauma.
Does everybody here
know what self-harm is?
I'm not going to explain it to
you because I don't know who's
in the audience, but it is
the act of hurting yourself
to release emotional pain,
and I often tell people
that I gave Charlie my scars, but
I gave her her own story, too,
and the story in this book takes her
from Minnesota to Tucson, Arizona,
where she learns how to
take care of herself.
She's homeless when the book begins.
She's briefly in a hospital.
She's kicked out because she doesn't
have insurance, and then she's put
on the bus by her mother
to go to Tucson to stay
with her old college friend, or
her old high school friend, Mikey,
and it's there that she falls
in with a group of people
at a coffee house that she
ends up working at and sort
of learns what kind of
life she wants to lead,
and the book is filled
with some very hard topics,
and as I've been traveling the
states this year talking to people
about the book, I've met a lot
of people who have read the book
and said, "You know, I don't know
if that really qualifies
as a young adult novel.
There's addiction in the book.
There's abuse.
There's assault," and
they say, "You know,
I'm not sure I want my kids
reading that," and I respect that,
but my answer to that is, "Don't you
remember high school and growing up
and how hard it could be?"
And my answer to that is, "You know,
suicide is the number one
cause of death for teenagers.
Why wouldn't you let them read a
book about it so they could learn
about it and process their
feelings if they had those thoughts
or if they knew somebody in their
school who had committed suicide?"
How can you tell a 15-year-old
girl who suffered assault
that she's old enough to go
through it but she's not old enough
to read a book about it so that
she can process her feelings?
Books like these need to be on the
shelf, and they need to be talked
about because kids who
suffer this stuff need a way
to process their feelings and
to heal, and they need to know
above all that they're not alone.
So I say that I write this
story-I wrote this story for a girl
that I met on the bus when I was
leaving my job at the University
of Minnesota, and she had
fresh scars on her arm,
and I didn't say anything to her,
and I always think I
should have talked to her,
and I should have told her,
"I'm where-I used to be
where you are right now, and
you're not alone, and I understand,
and you can talk to me, and
there is hope," but I didn't.
Instead I went home and I thought
about it, and I wrote a book
to that girl, and ever since I wrote
this book, I get letters from kids.
I got this letter from a girl named
Lily, and Lily said, "I'm Lily,
and I attend school in Illinois,
and in 2017 I will be 13 1/2 ,"
and Lily goes on to say, "In
the first grade I started
to notice the bullying
that was happening to me.
I got called 'heavy,' 'fat,' and I
felt stupid because it was horrible,
and it made me feel dumb," and later
in the letter she tells me that
"Sixth grade was when the big black
depression cloud started to form,
and I have never come out of that,"
and the first time that Lily tried
to commit suicide, she
was in the first grade,
and she tried to drink hair
gel, and she says in the letter,
"I didn't know how to do it.
It was gross.
Don't try it.
It tastes bad," and we might
think that's kind of funny,
but she was in the first
grade, and now she's 13 1/2.
She doesn't have any other
book that talks to her
about how she feels except for this
book, and at the end of the letter,
she tells me she's on her
third hospitalization,
but her mom got her this book
because she didn't have anywhere
else to turn, and her mom had no way
to talk to her about
what was going on,
and they read this book
together, and now they're
in counseling together, and
that's why difficult books
that might make you as
a parent or an educator
or a librarian feel a little big
uncomfortable, that's why books
like these actually matter to
kids because they want to talk
about that stuff that is
making them feel alone
and uncomfortable and marginalized.
When I was younger, this is the
story of how I became a writer,
and it has to do with my
mother who went to Georgetown.
There were four other kids in my
family, and they were much older
than I was, and they
were all in school,
and my mother was rightfully tired
after doing all that mothering
and getting them off to school and
giving them cereal and whatnot,
and so as soon as they
left, she would, you know,
light up a cigarette, get on
the couch, and open up a book,
and she was a voracious reader,
and I realized very early on that
if I wanted my mother
to pay attention to me,
I was going to have
to learn to read.
So I taught myself to read when I
was three by watching Sesame Street,
which I'm still an advocate of.
I love that show, and my mother
looked at me one day and said,
"Okay, it's on," and from
that day on, every day we went
down to the central public library
in Hollidaysburg, Pennsylvania,
and we spent hours there until my
brothers and sisters came home,
and she let me pick out whatever
book I wanted to pick out.
She didn't care if it was meant for
adults or if it was meant for kids.
She just wanted me to read,
and we talked about reading together
all the time, and I read things
that I probably shouldn't have
been reading, like maybe some books
that were like a little too sexy for
a 10-year-old, but I like to think
that those, you know, gave
me an education as well.
When we moved to Tucson, my
mother took a job in an office,
and I was really lonely, and it
was a huge difference from being
in Pennsylvania, and I didn't
have any friends, and I was 11.
So it was right about that age where
things start to happen for you,
but every weekend, my mother, all
90 pounds and five feet of her,
would lug home this giant IBM
Selectric typewriter from her office
and set it up on the
dresser in her bedroom
and let me write my
stories all weekend.
Every weekend she did that,
and then during the week,
she would let me read
them aloud to her,
and she would always
say, "That's great.
I love that.
How did you come up with that?"
And if you can be that person for
a kid where you have no judgment,
where you let them be
who they want to be,
you can literally save their life.
I would not have made it
through my adolescence
if I didn't have an
outlet like writing
and if I didn't have the support
that I had from my mother.
So if you can be that person who
brings that IBM Selectric typewriter
to a kid in your life, I hope
that you decide to be that person
because it really matters, and if
you're an educator or a librarian
who can put that book on a shelf for
a kid who maybe doesn't talk a lot
or seems like they
maybe don't have a place
to sleep that's consistent every
night, you should be that person.
One of the best conversations
I ever had with a librarian was
when I said, "Oh, I'm
really kind of sad now,"
because when I was growing up,
you went to check out books,
and you had to check them out with
the librarian, and you could talk,
and it had like a little cardboard
think inside that they would stamp,
and I said, "It's kind of sad now
because everything is
self-checkout," and she said,
"Actually, it's really good
that it's self-checkout
because now people and kids can go
pick out the books that they want
to pick out without feeling
embarrassed about bringing it
up to the counter," and
they said, "And also,"
this was the school
librarian, she said,
"I can tell which kids are checking
out which book multiple times,
and then I know that they need
that book and they need other books
like them and I know to order more
copies, and sometimes at the end
of the year if I see a kid that
has checked out a book 13 times,
I just tell them to take it home,
and I'll order another copy.
So it's actually a really
good thing that you can check
out books privately now as kids,"
and she said, "It's a good way
for me to keep track of what's
going on in their lives as well
because I see what they're reading,
and I know what we should be
concerned about in our school."
I'm going to read a brief section
of "Girl in Pieces," if that's okay,
and it's the beginning of the book,
and the book is told,
not in chapters.
It's told in three
sections, and partly that's
to reflect Charlie's psychological
makeup at the beginning
of the book having been
on the street for so long,
and then as the book goes
on, the sections get longer
and a little bit more
expansive as she learns to start
to feel comfortable in the world.
"Like a baby harp seal,
I'm all white.
My forearms are thickly
bandaged and heavy as clubs.
My thighs are wrapped
tightly, too; white gauze peeks
out from the shorts Nurse
Ava pulled from the lost
and found box behind
the nurses' station.
Like an orphan, I came
here with no clothes.
Like an orphan, I was wrapped in
a bedsheet and left on the lawn
of Regions Hospital in the
freezing sleet and snow,
blood seeping from
the flowered sheet.
The security guard who found me
was bathed in menthol cigarettes
and the flat stink
of machine coffee.
There was a curly forest of
white hair inside his nostrils.
He said, 'Holy Mother of God,
girl, what's been done to you?'
My mother didn't come to claim me.
But, I remember the
stars that night.
They were like salt against the sky,
like someone spilled the
shaker against very dark cloth.
That mattered to me,
their accidental beauty.
The last thing I thought
I might see before I died
on the cold, wet grass.
The girls here, they
try to get me to talk.
They want to know, 'What's
your story, morning glory?
Tell me your tail, snail.'
I hear their stories every day
in Group, at lunch, in Crafts,
at breakfast, at dinner, on and on.
These words that spill from them,
black memories, they can't stop.
Their stories are eating them
alive, turning them inside out.
They cannot stop talking.
I cut all my words out.
My heart was too full of them.
I room with Louisa.
Louisa is older and her hair is
like a red-and-gold noisy
ocean down her back.
There's so much of it,
she can't even keep it
in with braids or buns
or scrunchies.
Her hair smells like
strawberries; she smells better
than any girl I've ever known.
I could breathe her in forever.
My first night here, when she
lifted her blouse to change for bed,
in the moment before that
crazy hair fell over her body
like a protective cape,
I saw them, all of them,
and I sucked in my breath hard.
She said, 'Don't be
scared, little one.'
I wasn't scared.
I'd just never seen a
girl with skin like mine."
So the book I'm working
on now is a book
about a 16-year-old girl
named Tiger Toliver who lives
in a little town outside
Tucson, Arizona,
and her mother dies unexpectedly.
Now my own mother was sort
of the impetus for the story
because when she was seven,
her mother died unexpectedly,
and her father put my mother
and her brother in an orphanage
and sent a baby sister to live
with relatives in California,
and my mother never saw
her baby sister again,
and she lived in that orphanage for
three years until she was adopted
by a lovely couple that she
considered her parents for the rest
of her life, but I often
thing about the memories
that my mother would relate to me
about her time in the orphanage
or the things that she remembered
of her own mother and her father
and of growing up, and I just
started thinking about the stories
that our parents tell us
about the way that they used
to be before they were
parents and the things
that maybe they don't tell
us because-and I am a parent.
I have a 9-year-old
and a 4-year-old.
So I'm thinking really
hard about these things.
What things do you
really tell your kids?
How much of your past
do you want them
to know before maybe it might
be a little bit too heavy
for them to bear?
Because my mother telling me
about her past and her life
in the orphanage was really sad.
Maybe in some ways that was a little
too sad for me to know at that age
because my perception of my
mother shifted just a little bit.
Like, I felt like I needed to
almost take care of her in a way now
that I knew this little bit
of information about her.
So I started thinking about
Tiger Toliver and a girl
who loses her mother at the age of
16 and who's never known her father,
and how that death might spur her
to learn more about her mother,
and she might discover things about
why her mother was the way she was,
maybe like over protective, things
like that, but it's also a story
about building family from the
ground up because Tiger discovers
that she has an older half-sister
who has her own problems,
who maybe isn't going to be
the best mother or caretaker,
but comes out to take
care of Toliver anyway,
and the book also examines the
role of foster care in our society
and kids who are on the margins,
kids whose parents are unable
to take care of them because of
addiction, which is huge in Arizona.
Like the opioid addiction in Tucson
alone is just, it's out of control,
and almost 42 percent of the school
age kids in Tucson alone are living
in shelters or in their cars because
of the ravages of drug addiction,
and it's something we really
need to start thinking about.
So that's what that
book is about in part,
and it's also about the concept
of motherhood and mothering
and about a girl who is very lonely,
who is going to undergo an
incredible transformation
through the death of her mother.
Part of it is based on how I felt
when my own mother passed away.
You become a different person.
So it's a book about grief told
from Tiger Toliver's
16-year-old point of view.
I would love to take questions
at this point if anyone has any.
I will answer any question.
I can't really see back there.
>> Audience: How did you
get started as an author.
What was the impetus?
What was the idea and
thinking at the time?
>> Kathleen: Do you mean like
more or less how I decided
to send something out to see
if it would get published?
Well, I liked writing in school
a lot, and I never thought
that I would be a published
author, and I got a degree in poetry
because I didn't-I didn't, you
know, I never really thought
about writing fiction or,
you know, big, long books.
I liked writing my short snippets
of poetry because that appealed
to my darker nature, and when
I started writing this book,
I started writing it
using that poetic voice,
and it took me nine
years to write this book
and thirteen drafts
because I had two kids.
I lost my mother and my sister.
So I stopped writing for about a
year after that, which I also want
to say if you're a creative person,
things take as long as they take.
You know, sometimes life happens.
People will die.
You will have kids.
Wait it out and then go back
to work when you're ready.
Don't pressure yourself.
That's the most important
thing you need to know.
Whatever it is, whatever story
you're trying to tell, it can wait.
People will still be
there to read it.
You need to take care of yourself.
I met a literary agent and an editor
at the Taos Writers' Conference,
which I would recommend if you're
thinking about being a writer,
and that was-that was the first time
that I'd really had some
interest in the story.
I didn't have any friends who
were writing fiction at that time.
I'd been out of school
for quite some time,
but they were really interested
in it, and I spent a lot of time
with one agent revising the book
in many, many different ways
until I found a different agent and
actually she ended up selling it
like quite quickly, I
think within like a week.
So, it got very, very crazy,
but in terms of the process
of writing the book and taking nine
years, you know in the beginning
of writing the book, Charlie had a
twin, and everything that happens
in this book had happened before
that story actually started,
and after a couple of
years, I realized, you know,
I'm not telling the story
I really want to tell
because it's making
me uncomfortable,
and so gradually you lose things
in the process of writing.
I was like, I don't
need Charlie's twin.
She has this best friend
who's way too supportive.
The best friend goes.
Another best friend comes in who's
maybe a little bit more competitive
with Charlie.
Charlie had an okay
family in early drafts.
I eventually got rid of her family
because I needed Charlie to be
as alone as possible if readers,
especially the teen readers
that I wanted to reach, were
going to believe in her story
because they feel completely alone,
and I needed to have
Charlie be completely alone,
and it was through that whole
process that the story changed.
Other things happened.
There's a house early in the
book that Charlie ends at up
in the Minnesota winter where the
kids are being trafficked for sex,
and that house was based on
a house that I lived near,
a couple of blocks away from in
a neighborhood in Saint Paul,
Minnesota that's called Frog
Town, and I lived in Frog Town
for 13 years, and it's one of the
poorest neighborhoods in Minneapolis
and Saint Paul, and it turned out
that there was a house a couple
of blocks from me, and they
were keeping mung girls there
and selling them through
the back pages of magazines,
and the mung girls were afraid to
go back home because of the shame,
and so they stayed there, and
I never forgot about that story
and the fact that none of us in the
neighborhood knew what was going on.
Winters are long and
cold in Minnesota.
They last like seven months.
Nobody leaves their house except
to go to work and come back home.
We had no idea what was
going on in that house,
and I thought about
that for a long time.
I never forgot those girls feeling
alone and being afraid to go home
or wanting to run away
somewhere else, but they couldn't
because it was too cold, and so
I put part of that in this book,
and that's a way that real life
sometimes creeps into your fiction.
>> Audience: Yes, can you explain
the cover of the book, the concept,
and what it means and
including with your name.
Is that like erased and then so the
title could also-your name looks
like something's going on there?
Thank you.
>> Kathleen: So, Charlie Davis,
very early on you learn in the book
that one of the things
that gives her hope
and helps her feel better is art,
and she draws comics of her friends,
and she also does charcoal sketches,
and throughout the book she goes
to a library that really
exists in Tucson, Arizona.
All the places in the
book in Tucson are real.
She goes to the downtown Joel Valdex
Library, and she takes out books
on the Old Masters, and
she tries to copy them,
and when your editor sends
you a cover copy of your book,
they always say things like,
"It's fabulous, and we love it,"
and your job is really to say,
"Yeah, that's great," but, you know,
I will say honestly that I had some
hesitations on this cover because,
you know, those are cut
marks, right, and I was like,
"I don't want to upset people," but
then the longer that I looked at it,
the more I liked it because the
smudges are Charlie's charcoal
on the paper, and if you
buy the book in a bookstore,
you'll feel the texture
of the paper,
which feels like sketch paper.
So they did a really nice job.
So that's Charlie's
charcoal with the smudges,
and then they cut pieces
going through the name.
I think they did a fabulous job,
and it actually won a couple
of design awards, which I think is
great, but the cover also serves
as a way for readers to know
exactly what that book is about.
I don't think you could look at that
book and think that that's going
to be a roller coaster ride.
A reader who needs that book is
going to look at that book and say,
"Okay, this book is going to
talk about something painful,
and I'm going to read that
because I need to read that."
It tells girls who cut that
this is a book that they need.
It tells adults who have scars, like
me, "I'm going to read about that
because that's going to talk
about my experience in the world,"
and so I think that they
did-they had just a brilliant idea
when they came up with that cover,
and I asked my agent, "You know,
when they do the paperback, do you
think they will change the cover?"
And she said, "No, it's
an iconic cover now.
It's the pink book.
They're never going to change
that cover," and I have come
to love that cover a lot.
>> Audience: Hi.
I came here late, and I didn't
read your book, and I apologize.
>> Kathleen: Are you here for David
Baldacci because he'll be here soon?
>> Audience: Actually,
no, I'm here for you.
My daughter was like, "Whoa,
I've heard of that book.
I really want to go visit,"
and so, and I'm a mother
of a teenage daughter
who's 14 and a mother
of a soon-to-be teenage
daughter who's 11,
and I found your personal story very
compelling about how long it takes
and it takes what it takes in order
to be creative, but-and also the bit
that you just read from your book
and the story that you just told
about the girls in
Minnesota, and whew.
So my question for you is as a
mother who's anticipating, you know,
growing girls, what do you
recommend for those of us
who have teenage daughters in
this very complicated world?
>> Kathleen: One, don't
forget what you felt
like as a teenage girl ever.
Like, don't forget that.
You need that.
Two, listen.
Whatever they have to say, listen.
If they call you at
2 am and they ask
for a ride home, just go get them.
Don't' ask questions.
Don't lecture.
Just go get them.
You remember exactly how hard
it was, and the thing is is
that you're trying to think,
"I want to protect you
so you don't feel those
feelings that I felt."
That's impossible.
All you can do is stay
by their side.
That's it.
I wrote this book partly because
I want people to start talking
about why our girls are trying
to make themselves smaller.
More than a million girls
harm themselves every year.
Why are they trying to
make themselves disappear?
Why? Why are we letting them?
The best thing that I think that
you can do if you really want
to be active is to go to
your daughter's school,
talk to her counselor or
a teacher that she likes,
and start a girls' club after
school or during school hours.
I visited a girls' empowerment
group at Tucson High School,
and this was the only
place that these girls felt
like they could get support,
sitting in this little space
in the band room at 9:30 am and
talking about their feelings
with the school counselor.
Like literally I think that
that group was saving some
of the lives of those girls.
They were in bad spots.
I felt honored to be sitting there
with them sharing their stories
with me because it's bad, and
I don't mean to get political
on everybody, but the person that's
in the White House, that's bad.
That person is not a friend to
women, and for girls to see that,
that you can get elected to
that is so painful and damaging,
and for girls to try to tell
people when they've been assaulted
and not be listened
to is so damaging,
and all I can tell you is
that you need to listen.
Try to get girls together so that
they can talk about their feelings
in a safe and supportive
atmosphere and just never forget
that even though you want their
life to be different than the life
that maybe you led as a
teenager, you can't control that.
All you can do is stick by
her side and be her parent
and her friend and her listener.
[Applause] One of the-one of the
things that I have thought a lot
about this year, particularly
because I will probably
always write difficult books
about difficult subjects
is the responsibility
of the young adult author for
teenagers who read your books,
and if you're going to talk about
this stuff, it's your responsibility
to put hope in that book.
There has to be a glimmer of
hope at the end of the story.
A door has to be cracked, and
light has to come through,
or you haven't done your job.
You can read as many books
marketed to adults as you want,
and the story can end with
[inaudible] or looking
at the sunset, and you don't know
what happens to the characters.
It might turn out to be a
little dark, but for teenagers
who have a whole possibility
of a life in front of them,
you absolutely must have hope.
Hope has to be in your book, and
I give Charlie that at the end,
and it's a hope that she works for
on her own through trial and error
because not everybody
has access to therapists
or has a supportive school counselor
or a supportive family
group that they can talk to.
Sometimes you have to do it on
your own, and sometimes you slip
and fall, but you have to
learn that that's okay, too,
and I think that that's one of the
things that I have loved the most
about the response to this book
is the fact that people feel like
and teenagers feel like
their story has been told
and that they have hope now
because I gave this character
some hope at the end of the book.
Do we have any more questions?
>> Audience: I just wanted to
thank you for the Writers' Almanac.
That got me through my
first years of teaching.
It aired right before I went into
the building, and I would sit
and wait, drink my hot
chocolate, and listen to poems,
and it would set me for my day,
and I've used them many
times in the classroom.
>> Kathleen: Right.
>> Audience: And in
particular remember one
about a-describing a dog with
cancer, and my mother had died
of cancer about a year prior
to that and just crying
in my car before work
in the morning.
Anyway, it's wonderful, and I'm
glad that it's still out there
and it still exists, and do you
know Garrison Keeler personally?
>> Kathleen: I do.
He's a, you know, it's actually a
great character writing tool doing
the research for these because
he'll send you the topics.
They've been doing it for
a couple of years now,
and he'll send you
the topics over email,
and they-it's literary biography and
history, and you have to write them,
you have to research them like super
quickly and send him the material,
but you also have to read it
out loud kind of in his voice
because then he's going
to go record it,
so you don't really have
a lot of room for editing.
So I read something, and then I
have to say to myself in the corner
of my room surrounded by
Legos, "Today's the birthday
of Ludwig von Beethoven,
whose 'Ode to Joy,'" you know,
you have to do it in his voice,
and he's a terribly nice man,
and I hope that he keeps doing it
for a long time, and there are three
of us who do research for him.
So it's literally-I
learn something new
like literally every
day, but I like it.
>> Audience: Thank you.
>> Audience: Hello.
Hello.
>> Kathleen: Hi.
>> Audience: I have
a technical question.
>> Kathleen: Okay.
Is it about the microphone
because I can't answer that?
>> Audience: No, it's very nice.
[Laughter] My question is you
seem to be one of the few authors
that does not have a Wikipedia page.
>> Kathleen: I don't.
Are you offering?
I don't know how to do that.
>> Audience: Can you
explain your choice?
>> Kathleen: [Laughter]
It's not my choice.
I don't know who sets that up.
>> Audience: On my way here I did
a lot of research, and [laughter]-
>> Kathleen: You can do it.
Make sure that you say I'm 6'2"
and that I'm willowy and blonde.
[Laughter]
>> Audience: I don't know how
the other authors got it done.
>> Kathleen: I think that-I
think anybody can just go on
and make a page for
anybody, can't they?
I don't know.
There's only so much I can do.
[Laughter] I have these kids, and
they want me to take care of them,
and I have to read to them,
and they're getting older.
>> Audience: Thank you.
>> Kathleen: Thank you.
That's a good question.
I'll tell my agent.
Julie, I don't have
a Wikipedia page.
Okay.
>> Audience: So our
15-year-old read the book,
and she kept on telling
my husband and I,
"You have to read this
book," and it's so gripping.
It's just, it's amazing,
and I'm really surprised
that the room is not overflowing.
I expected-
>> Kathleen: I think this
is a pretty good crowd.
>> Audience: Yeah, but I
really expected-My question is,
it might sound a bit weird,
but is there-I really feel
like there's a movie in the book,
and the movie is a good one.
Have you thought about it?
Has anybody approached you?
>> Kathleen: You know, I
haven't been approached,
but I would feel fine
if there was a movie.
I think that would be great.
Like I'm not one of
those writers who's like,
"Oh, movie, my precious gem."
I think that would be awesome.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I would watch that movie.
I think that could be a good movie.
I would be totally excited.
You know, I like all this stuff that
comes along with being an author,
I love getting these letters.
I like people coming up to me
in the bookstore and saying,
"Are you the person who wrote that
book on that child [inaudible]?"
I like meeting people.
Movie? Sounds like a
good brass ring to me.
I'll take it, you know.
So that would be great, and so you
said your husband read this book,
too?
>> Audience: Yeah, we're
reading it together.
>> Kathleen: You know I
think that's really great.
I think that brings up a good
point that if there are books
that you're a little worried
about your teenagers
reading, read them together.
You know, it might like help
you as much as it helps them,
and it gives you something
to talk about.
Like your teenagers, they're
not just people you forget about
and say, "Go watch TV by yourself,
and you go to school every day
for eight hours and I see you
at night for like 35 minutes."
Read the book with them.
Just like you watch a movie
or talk about a TV show
because that can be a great
way to open up a conversation
that maybe before you were a
little afraid-you were afraid
of how you'd start it, and it can
create a lot of, I think, empathy
and communication between parents
and their kids reading together.
I love reading with my kids.
We end up talking about
some really great stuff.
So, I'm sorry there's not a
bigger crowd, but I like it.
[Laughter] Some people are
here for David Baldacci,
and they are just like,
"What am I watching?
This is not what I came for."
So, you know-
>> Audience: I have
a second question.
>> Kathleen: Oh, sure.
>> Audience: I just wanted
to know a little bit more
about the-what happened for
you when you did connect
with a literary agent and-
>> Kathleen: Like when I connected?
>> Audience: Yeah, how that
all played out and just sort
of what the process was, yeah.
>> Kathleen: Well there's
no-the process, you know,
if you want to find an agent,
one of the ways you can do is go
to a writers' conference
and pay extra
to have a little private manuscript
consultation, and they'll look
at like 20 pages and offer you
advice, and sometimes in my case
with that agent, she
offered to represent me.
I didn't know anything about
that process at the time.
I was like, "Oh, this sounds great.
Of course, love me.
I may not ever get an agent
again," and I signed with her,
and it turned out in
the end her vision
for the book was not
my vision for the book.
She really wanted to steer the
book in a more adult direction,
and I didn't want to go there
because I had a young character
and I was a young person, and so
we parted ways like very amicably,
and then I simply got on my
computer, and I looked up agents,
and I saw what books they had
represented that might be similar
to mine, and I will tell you no lie.
One of the reasons that I sent a
query to my agent, Julie Stevenson,
was because she looked
really nice in her picture.
[Laughter] She had a good
bio, but looking at her,
I just felt this connection like,
"I bet she would like my book,"
and I can't-I cannot
explain it, but she did.
She really championed this book.
She got it right away.
She sent me notes on that
book and how she would edit it
and where she was going to
send it and what her vision was
for it before I even
signed with her.
So if you're looking for an agent,
make sure that you find
someone who's enthusiastic
about that process
and about your book.
First and foremost, they
should really love that book,
and they should want
to work with you.
You know, don't find someone who has
maybe like a whole stable of writers
because maybe you'll feel, you
know, lost amid all those writers.
I found somebody who
was committed to me,
and I made the right decision.
>> Audience: Congratulations.
>> Kathleen: Thank you.
It's been a great year.
Hi.
>> Audience: Hi.
I was wondering what would
you say your favorite book
or author would be and why?
>> Kathleen: When I was
growing up or right now?
>> Audience: Both.
>> Kathleen: So when I was
growing up, the first book
that I truly loved that I felt like
was speaking to me was "Catcher
in the Rye," and it was my
mother's old paperback from 1952
where Holden Caulfield is wearing
what they call in the book,
you know, his people killing head,
but he was depressed and suicidal,
and I hadn't read that in a book
yet, and I was like, "My God,
that's me," and as I read
that book as an adult,
I can see that there were
problems with Holden's character,
but as a teenager, I loved
that book, and I still love it,
and I reread it every year.
I'm also wearing my "Wrinkle
in Time" t-shirt because I love
that book, and I am
so looking forward
to seeing the movie, aren't you?
Oprah is in it.
That's right.
I would like Oprah to
play Charlie Davis.
I would watch that.
Some of the books that I've recently
read that I really liked were
"The First Time She
Drowned," by Kerry Kletter,
which is a young adult novel, "Girls
in the Moon," by Janet McNally,
which is a young adult novel
about a girl whose mother
was an Indy pop musician
in the 90s, and I love that story.
It's a lot, it's about
finding yourself and finding
who your parents are and
forging a life for yourself.
>> Audience: Okay, well, I'm
one of those people who came
for the next talk,
so I just got here.
>> Kathleen: Oh, hi.
Thanks for coming.
Thanks for staying.
I hope it was informative.
You want to see-you
can see my book cover.
>> Audience: Who's the artist?
My other question is, you know,
you may have answered this already
in your talk, so one
is how do you overcome
like when you don't get inspiration
anymore, like you run dry generally?
And the second question
is do you ever,
ever like ponder how people
will interpret, you know,
what you're saying, and
how do you handle it
when people misinterpret
what you wrote
in your email feedbacks
or snail mail?
Thank you.
>> Kathleen: Oh, you
mean like if I respond
to a person who writes me a letter?
>> Audience: Well, like,
let's say like you're writing,
and you have one interpretation.
>> Kathleen: Oh.
>> Audience: But like
have you ever had people
like either misunderstand
you or give
like a totally different
interpretation
than you really liked, and could
you describe some of those?
>> Kathleen: Well, first,
I think that, you know,
everybody who reads a book is going
to come away with different things
about that book, and you
could have like ten people
who have read the same book,
and all ten of them are going
to have a different opinion of
it, and all ten of them are going
to find something in that
book that really touched them
that might be different
from the other ten people.
So that's the reason I
love novels and writing
because there isn't just one
yes or no, and in the new book
that I'm working on right now,
Tiger Toliver really loves to read,
but she doesn't call
herself book smart.
She just likes the act of reading.
She doesn't like sitting
in her English Lit class
because every time she really
wants to talk about something
that happened in the book, the
teacher says, "Well, actually,
no" because they're more interested
in telling her about literary terms
and what she should be thinking
and how to dissect a book and not
about how a book makes you
feel, and I'm more in that camp.
I like how a book makes you feel.
I like thinking about craft,
too, but if somebody comes
up with a different
interpretation of my book, you know,
I'm not going to argue with them.
I think that's interesting.
I would probably say, "Well,
where did you see that?
Where did you find that?"
And as for inspiration, and I will
end because I only have one minute,
and I know like you're
waiting for David Baldacci
and he's probably here [laughter].
It's like "Get her off," but
so last night, they, you know,
they gave this really great
award to Dennis Johnson,
who is a great fiction writer
who passed away, right,
and I was telling my agent that he
visited this program that I used
to work for at the
University of Minnesota,
and one of the graduate students
asked him, "So, you know,
like what do you do like if you
don't know what to write and you're
like you have writer's block?"
And he was like, and I don't know
if this is true what he said
or if he just, you know.
I like to think it's true.
He was a really funny
person in person.
I really liked meeting him.
He said, "[Sigh] You
know, I watch a lot of TV.
I just-I got this cabin that
I-you know, I watch a lot of TV,
and then my wife comes over to me,
and she says, 'We need a new roof,
and I get up and turn off the TV,
and I go write, and I sell a book,
[laughter], and I go out to her,
and I do some teaching gigs,
and then I come back, and I turn
the TV on, and then a couple
of years later she says, 'We've
got to pay the electric bill,
and I get up, and
I turn off the TV,
and then I go write
something, and I sell it."
And you know what?
That's inspiration.
Sometimes you just get up and
turn off the TV and put your butt
in the seat, turn off
your iPhone, your iPad,
your i-Whatever and write the story.
That's it.
Thank you so much.
[Applause]
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.